I've been casually playing Spider-Man 2
over the last couple of weeks I got to
say this game is fun as heck the
traversal upgrade with wings and crispy
smooth web slinging is awesome I
questioned the wings at first but man I
love them it really feels like you're
flying through the Burrows of Queens
Brooklyn and Manhattan the map is about
double in size and you can really tell
when you're making the flight across
East River Ray tracing and Graphics have
really been dialed in finding the right
balance between performance and Fidelity
in my lizard brain opinion I mean look
at my reflection and these people in the
window the combat is evolved and now
having control of Peter and Miles with
their own styles of Teek and fighting
and to the people who feel that fighting
is repetitive it's like dudes don't
Button Mash be a Spider-Man get Creator
I don't want to spoil the story but
there's this dude this lady that guy
this gal her him slimy toothy guy and of
course the Spider-Man but what do you
want to know about the game let me know
and thanks to Sony and Insomniac games
because